сюди на 5 і на момент прокуратури та
збувалося зазвичай акції протесту грамоті
пензля вийшла за haste це детективі він
Або ж позову збоку день прокуратурою у
тим самим через день раб новий прем'єр
кремля київ о бок структур у німецькому
фонд фридриха наумана прикрашають ще
конфлікт вичерпали шляхом
цивілізованого політичного діалогу
спринт на подібну напої лем але думала
немає у б дві служби на можуть самі
посуді думаю тис я обожнюю дуже тиковим
ще президент так не дружу зовсім на вигляд
на прагу манту love
ситуаційні просто ліпаза ти всередину ще
в зао особи і конфлікт е і c звірити про
тещу набу серйозно просили обійтися
такі конфлікти чи треба можеш в частині
шоти
а j9 пробувати 2 2 складаємося з нової качки
адже всі вам українці і менше шансів
на ралі боротьбу за велику корупцію
поважаючи експорт до
нальна мцр кулясова робота з мінімото
генпрокуратуру
онеу довго з рукою перспективі я обожнюю
Україна
треба сіце і реформі заворот йому руку
ямою на алмазі україна досі на успіх
помруть без корупції та він з таким funk у
українському представництві
transparency international вдягається
на стику з детективі Іванову
ситуація на просто оджіно бута і по
видути пара війною кирик навчених
кримінальних промо джей дроту об брут
до екшену бу
не зуб інете екшона просто не буду
жити я не знаю зате різанини може бути до
заходу може зник ні фінансово не
можеш ось і шукай ну тут уже серйозніше
заходи касаційної бадьорий це боротьба
skrux & в Україні триватимуть всі
розвивалося і це красиво темпами там
часто інцидент ніжний півтону bull
взялася розслідувати і служби б спайкою
україни у європейських експертів того
травневих активісти у пукани травень
повинності рахунок об'єктивності
розслідування конфлікту між начебто цією
туш виймаєте на світ скажи ти за по
рибі вам буде тауразі потреби знав
прийти сюди пити стіни прокуратури